if you had to battle 153 killer ninjas
what would you do you've been chosen to
join the most dangerous exam your
country has ever seen two faces to be
exact and will have to stay alive by one
flirting with girls raging teenage
hormones and relying on your enemy's big
fat ego in order to win I'm going to
break down the mistakes made what you
should do and how to beat the first two
faces of the tunin exam in Naruto these
kids will wish they never tried to be
Ninja Warriors Naruto and his two uh
friends here Sasuke and Sakura are
training to be the sickest ninjas ever
they find out that they've just been
chosen by their teacher o goodie to join
the tunin exam a lethal competition
where the best wannabe ninjas will
compete to win or die in the most insane
death games joining other top students
from different nations they all head
into the exam room and get ready to
begin the first test but Saga gets
worried she won't be able to keep up
with these two and she's right thousands
have suffered horrifying Fates died lost
their minds become disabled from taking
this exam and this nice guy bumps into
them he failed like four times by the
way and he thinks the TuneIn exams are
meant to bring different Nations closer
together that's funny he's wrong but he
warns them of the future Killers they're
about to face Naruto doesn't think much
and says he's going to kick everybody's
ass cuz that's what he likes to do
makeing enemies right before they even
start nice job this guy comes in and
announces the first test of the TuneIn
exam is about to begin stating the rules
of the first test everyone gets 10
points the test has 10 problems worth
one point each and they will lose one
point if they get a question wrong if
they are caught cheating they will lose
two points each and everyone in each of
the groups must pass to together or they
all fail they look around and see that
they're being watched if anyone
misbehaves or gets caught they will get
kicked out and anyone that gets zero
points will fail automatically the 153
candidates begin the first exam starts 1
hour time limit and everybody is
freaking out like smarty pan Sakura over
here cuz her brains can't cover for
Naruto this time but this test is
nothing like they've ever seen and they
realize no one can solve any of this and
that's when Sakura figures out what's
really going on a test that no one can
do means that most will try and cheat
and wonders if this is part of the real
test Naruto tries to not panic while
Sasuke nearby figures out the same thing
in a matter of seconds and realizes that
this is a test within a test they must
collect information using all of the
Ninja techniques that they've learned
deception and concealment techniques
while not getting caught just like real
ninjas this means someone in here must
know the real answers he starts looking
around for him meanwhile everyone else
quickly start using all of their best
skills using animals hearing the stroke
system of their pencil to figure out
what's being written using power of
communication but to help them and their
team beat this test except Naruto ever
keeps freaking his boobs off cuz he
knows if he doesn't pass this test he
will never become the strongest Ninja on
Earth and will never become the hok KAG
of this Village but then this girl this
angel of a human being next to him
ginata she loves him by the way offers
to show him her work and that's when a
knife slices past his face a student
right behind him has been disqualified
freaking Naruto out and he refuses the
girl's help not wanting to get caught
and just then students start dropping
like flies as only the cunning survive
another one of the students gets caught
and his than beaten up by the teachers
for cheating no mercy here okay Naruto
is acting so dumb but he could have
predicted all of this I mean let me
explain his powers are to change forms
and clone himself and if that was the
case then it doesn't make sense how he
just acted like he did right now he is
prepared to do whatever it takes to win
we know it this guy is more obsessed
about being a ninja about being a hake
than anybody here and yet he's stupid
ninja school is about becoming ninjas
and ninjas are sneaky and this means he
should have predicted that this school
would have tried to one up them every
chance they get and should have assumed
to be sneaky 24/7 I know it's not his
natural heads space and not his natural
Mo but these guys had a heads up about
when and where the exam would take place
5 days ago okay if I was him I would
have cloned myself and switched my
identity with one of the examiners or
teachers in order to get more
information about the test because we
all know Naruto can change himself to
look like different people so why
doesn't he do that and head on over and
try to learn more about the test in
advance because doing a test that will
determine whether or not you pass or
fail the one job you really want as bad
as Naruto does makes him not preparing
or doing whatever he can can to win for
this even more shocking he has the
ability to figure this out he just
needed to use two brain cells to do it
20 minutes left of the test students
start rushing to figure out all the
answers before they all fail and the
teacher finally gives them the final
question for this test but something is
off he States the rules for the final
question if they choose to answer two
horrifying things will happen if they
fail one them and their teammates will
immediately be disqualified from this
test and two they will never be able to
take the TuneIn exams ever again or they
can quit the test early right now and
try again next year and then the weak
students played safe leaving only the
toughest badasses in the room except one
or so they think these two wonder what
teammate Naruto is going to do and since
there's no way that he can pass the test
and that's when he puts his hand up and
shocks them all that he's given up but
then he slams it on the table with
confidence saying that he will become
the ultimate ninja the hok no matter
what even if he fails and he will never
quit thinking like a winner his
confidence inspires the rest of the
students to stay impressing the teacher
but then he reveals that their decision
to stay behind despite the huge risks
for them and their teammate was actually
the final test test and they've all
passed and then Naruto so quickly leaves
his body because then realize oh thank
the good Lord I didn't actually have to
do this test and he learned that being
brave and confident is what being a
cheting leader is all about so then they
want to celebrate but then suddenly
another teacher swings in and she will
be taking care of their second exam but
warrs more than half of them will die by
the end of the next test in the forest
of death and here she gives them
literally a waiver a contract to sign so
that way she can legally pick up their
corpses when they die and then the
parents can't sue them and then she
gives the rules of the next test
anything goes each team will get one
scroll they must protect half of the
students which is 13 teams will get one
Heaven scroll and the other will get one
Earth scroll in order to pass they must
bring both types of Scrolls to the tower
in the center of this Forest which is 10
km from here within 5 days which is 120
hours no one knows who has which scroll
and we'll also have to face every single
Monster on Earth inside of this Forest
which has Fierce people eating animals
poison bugs poisonous weeds and oh heck
of a lot more if all the members can't
make it with both scrolls they fail if
any member doesn't make it to the tower
they fail if any team member loses a
member they fail and no one can look
inside of their Scrolls until they reach
the tower no cheating and then the gate
opens and the teams rush into the forest
to look for the other Scrolls not
realizing that a real life serial killer
has infiltrated this group and that's
when the forest quickly gets to work and
kills some of the students death by
blood sucking leeches and their
horrifying screams Echo throughout the
woods including Naruto's group putting
them on edge for what's to come and he
returns from a quick bathroom break and
that was his biggest mistake Sasuke
starts beating him alive and Saga begs
them to stop and thinks he'd lost his
mind but he tells her what no one else
could ever figure out this isn't the
real Naruto sharing her cuz she thinks
he's crazy and he tells her the real
Naruto had a scratch on his face and
he's right-handed and Naruto here smiles
evily and attacks them Sasuke quickly
counters with fire style flower Jes
blasting fire shots and the two draw a
knives and he quickly finds the real
Naruto tied up nearby he frees him but
exposes himself nearly getting killed
and the real Naruto saves him and the
team sends this guy packing now that the
group is recovering from shock they all
realize that they now can't even trust
each other okay what happened just now
is the perfect example of why what
they're doing sucks and is flawed
they're focusing on getting Scrolls when
they should focus on the student
hierarchy let me explain since the
beginning their goal has been to win the
exams but these guys are thinking too
small trying to win without considering
their opponent's capabilities will only
make things harder the faster and more
efficient way to win would be to do
something similar to what is known as
grading on a curve you know when a
teacher grades a student based on where
they are in comparison to the other
students and not how good they actually
are if a student gets a D in class but
the class averages a b then grading on a
curve might actually bring the D student
up to a c minus basically bringing
everyone down to meet the shittier
student this is exactly what naroto
should be doing instead of trying to
rise to the top though you and I both
know he's not going to do that but he
should try to bring the other students
down by first analyzing their opponent's
capabilities there's a lot of teams out
here and have people with perceptive or
sensory abilities but team K and I here
the one that Naruto met in test one is
the only team here with all three ninjas
have unique highlevel senses stealth and
reconnaissance techniques from their
family lines kba with aramaru and sent
tracking kinata with a Byakugan and
Shino with his bugs skills they have are
beyond the basics that every ninja gets
taught and don't seem to be coming with
other same level ninjas which makes that
group valuable and dangerous I would
first work on finding this group and
take them out using Naruto to butter up
this one member of the team because as
we saw in exam one and because we know
she loves him we're going to lure her in
with sweet empty promises about our
future together because she is totally
going to buy that then I'm going to
Gaslight her and manipulate her into
helping us take her team out because she
wants to out of love and then once her
teammates are taken care of I would
slice her throat and put her out of the
picture because the only way Naruto
really could win this game is by playing
dirty instead of trying to play the game
the right way cuz that's lame who wants
to play the game the right way not me
Sasuke then hears something sinister
nearby unaware that he's about to meet a
real life serial killer he comes up with
a game plan and makes up a secret long
ass password for the group to he was
just just in case yeah it works great
it's a passo though that might just save
their life within the next 1 minute back
outside of the forest the exam
instructor anko discovers something that
turns her face white and she finds that
three students have been killed by an
actual professional killer but notices
their faces have been stolen meaning the
Killer is actually posing as a student
she tells her men to warn Lord Hokage
about this and send in soldiers to stop
this as soon as possible and she heads
in to try and save her other students
back inside the gang repeats the
password for safety and Sakura rattles
it off confidently but Naruto says he's
already forgot which pisses Sasuke off
cuz understandably but that's when they
sense trouble and take cover for a
second before coming back out from the
bushes and Sakura gives Sasuke the
password proving she's not a fake and
Naruto returns and also remembers their
password which horrifies Sasuke to the
Bone because the real Naruto would never
remember the real password and that's
how they figured out this Naruto is fake
and has revealed himself and transforms
into this evil person Sasuke mentions he
could sense they were being watched so
he came up with a long ass password on
purpose to try and catch them out
however they wonder where the real
Naruto is this enemy tells them
something that shouldn't be possible he
wants the scroll that they have and
declares that he has an earth scroll and
swallows it right in front of them and
then he suddenly stops them from moving
with something they've never felt before
paralyzing fear these two sense for
thirst for actual human blood and have
no idea what the hell is going on
wondering who this person is Sakura
notices more bad news Sasuke now in
shock his ninja senses are telling him
this enemy is death desperately trying
to reach for his knife he's able to do
what he has to do and wipes out the fear
with pain and the two manag to barely
Escape okay well it might see seem like
we're screwed I would use some tactics
from a famous old farty Chinese book and
combin it with our raging teenage
hormones let me explain Sasuke freaking
out right now to this level means this
person even though we don't know who it
is is Super Evil And since we don't know
the full capabilities of this person and
we're teenagers it means we're already
at a disadvantage thanks to a 2,500 year
old military tactic written work and it
basically says if you don't know the
enemy but know yourself your chances of
winning are about 5050 but if you don't
know the enemy and don't even know
yourself you're screwed not only do we
not know who this enemy is and even if
we were sick badass ninjas we are still
snotty noos teenagers raging with
hormones and since when do teenagers
even know themselves just saying which
makes our disadvantage here times too if
I was them I would run away but i' do it
in style I'd announce out loud that I
have the Scrolls while hauling ass and I
would definitely notice any straggler
students nearby that would be attracted
to our location which I could then use
them as Shields of meat and a source of
distraction that could slow down the
enemy while giving us a chance to gain
further ground in worst case if I'm
Sasuke and I know Saga loves me I will
let her take one for the team and use
her as my own Shield of meat to stop
this enemy so then I can't get away cuz
teammates help each other out thanks
Sakura you're the best Naruto tries
looking for his teammates but gets
brutally eaten by this wild snake about
to be digested by flesh eating acid he
realizes that he hasn't settled his
with Sasuke and if he dies they won't
know who the better ninja is and this
pisses him off and forces him up
whipping out some Shadow clone judu and
he bursts out of the snake's stomach and
runs off to go find his friends heading
straight towards Sasuke he tries to
think clearly and figures out how to
escape Sakura sees Sasuke horrified for
the first time and realizes they're
screwed this snake shows up behind them
and Strikes and they see something even
more horrifying pop out of its body the
killer he charges at Sasuke and is about
to kill him but is stopped by Naruto
announcing he's returned he tells Sasuke
that he forgot the ninja password whoops
Sasuke begs Naruto to run cuz this chick
will kill them all but Naruto says Nah
Ballers got to play I love this guy the
Kaya gives them one chance to escape
with their lives if they hand over their
scroll to her they will all live knowing
they can't defeat him Sasuke actually
tosses over their scroll but his
intercepted by Naruto and he punches
Sasuke for being such a scaredy cat
calling Sasuke an imposter and is not
the man that Naruto knows because this
time he knows what Sasuke doesn't this
killer will never let them leave alive
the killer smiles and tells them he's
right Naruto charges at and summons a
Jutsu power and the killer sends a snake
his way beating him up he ends up back
in the snake's mouth but that was the
snake's biggest mistake and suddenly
happens and Naruto wakes up his eyes red
sharking the killer she recognizes those
eyes and Naruto loses control and gets
10 times stronger the snake now charges
at Sasuke but Naruto saves him holding
back the entire monster and he lets
Sasuke know that he is not the man he
knows anymore cuz he's a scaredy cat the
snake quickly picks up Naruto and beats
him up this time for good but this
killer examines Naruto like a pet and
knows that when Naruto's emotions get
high he can access a mythical power
known as the nine tals and spots a seal
on his stomach and the killer activates
a Jutsu and turns him back into normal
power level Naruto by force okay well
looks like we can win this one we could
have figured out by using the killer
known as orochimaru's own ego let me
explain Naruto is clearly powerful as
balls when he gets pissed off but this
is exactly why he should have been more
careful because how powerful is the most
powerful gun in the world if the person
using it has never held a gun before it
is both super dangerous and harmless at
the same time at this point he struggles
to control the power of his ninet tales
chakra and it only comes out when he
gets super emotional and during moments
of high stress situations similar to
when a regular person's fight ORF flight
system in the body happens during high
stress situations this happens when your
brain locks and it prevents your body
from Wrecking itself and then gets
unlocked and gives you a boost in
temporary strength and senses but this
extra power is temporary and happens
involuntary this is basically what
happened to Naruto just now now while
he's super powerful he really shouldn't
have relied on his temporary power to be
fair though I don't think he even really
knew he had it at this point if I was
him I would have first stayed in the
bushes and not announced our arrival
since the only thing we had was the
element of surprise and while Orochi
maro's weakness might not be so obvious
right now there are a few things we
could focus on watching from the bushes
we could have seen his primary focus was
on Sasuke which means his Focus would be
on him at all times and because of this
and we still have enough energy I would
exploit some type of distractions like
using Shadow clones to strategically
create distractions that would give him
and Sasuke a head start through the
forest while Orochimaru and Naruto both
can fight well in the forest escaping
through this terrain will help us avoid
orochimaru's long- raged attacks which
he specializes in within open spaces and
relies more on summoning snakes whenin
the forest which will now be less of an
issue for us in worst case getting a
head start could give us time to figure
out our next move while not being
cornered and fighting out of desperation
and not thinking clearly one thing we
would gain is knowing one of
orochimaru's weakness it's his ego which
we could appeal to if he'd catch up to
us by basically sucking up to him and
admire his skill and suggest that they
should have some kind of challenge given
his compe competitive nature this will
create more opportunities for Naruto to
escape while Orochimaru is focused on
the challenge or maybe Naruto shouldn't
be such a goody two shoes and offer up
one of his friends excited he tells
unconscious Naruto that his chakra
powers and the Ninetales are beginning
to sink up and he's excited to see what
he does next taking the scroll from him
he throws him and sees Naruto passed out
Sakura also calls Sasuke a coward that
was her biggest mistake think a girl
call him this is the last straw and
forces Sasuke balls to finally drop and
then he's ready to take on his greatest
enemy which is just what this killer
wants he watches Sasuke curiously and
wants to confirm his true power changing
his eyes to a new power level he
activates dragon flame Jutsu and tells
him he has to survive so he can finally
defeat his older brother one day it's a
really sad backstory but moving on he
charges at him and busts out knives and
goes hand-to-hand combat and goes
apeshit but this time he can see all the
enemies moves combining new moves he
ties them up and blasts his ass for good
and wins the match but not really sh
walks at all Fin and dandy and paralyzes
them with their powers a final time and
at his Mercy he says he's impressed at a
shing gun powers and then he finally
formally introduces himself as the
person we all know Orochimaru level
S-Class extremely dangerous and a person
on the most wanted list he wants Sasuke
for something horrifying but tells him
that they'll meet again soon and he
bites Sasuke's neck like a vampire and
gives him a Parting Gift Sasuke then
drops in agonizing pain and he
disappears leaving Sakura alone with her
unconscious teammates confused and
helpless while anko runs into Orochimaru
and she recognizes her old Master turned
evil and she prepares to kill him but
she has no match and quickly gets
defeated or shimaru says he's not here
to defeat Lord oag just yet and wants to
look at the talent in the exams but he
doesn't say why and reveals to anko oh
by the way I gave one of your precious
students the same curse mark as her
because he's going to be the perfect
host body for him to use if he survives
the curse thanks to his Clans uiha
Powers about to leave he tells anko to
watch what she does because there are
two other serial killers just like him
hiding within the exam Vanishing and
leaving his dagger behind anko rushes
off to tell the exam board what just
happened but runs into these two wild
tigers still weak and dizzy she gets
saved by Special Forces Von bu Black Ops
who tell her that they received a call
about an emergency in the exam and they
warn her that the exam should be
canceled immediately so they can hunt
down the bad guy and she begs them to
keep it going because she's stupid and
also to let her go to the tower in order
to finish the exam because it's just
that important she tells them to warn
Lord Hokage what's going on and she'll
explain later meanwhile Sakura here
moves everyone to shelter not realizing
that she's being watched by orochimaru's
men waiting for the perfect time to
strike the next morning Sakura is on
edge suddenly a squirrel scares Sakura
coming out and she nearly kills it
thinking she's getting too paranoid and
not realizes that she just avoided a
paper bomb strapped to it aroim maro's
men finally reveal themselves scaring
Sakura but tell her they don't want her
they've come for Sasuke asking her to
wake him up Sakura demands to know
what's going on to Sasuke's neck they
ignore her and prepare to kill her to
get to Sasuke this guy attacks but
suddenly another student named Lee shows
up and declares that he'll save his
future wife and confuses her and that
he'll always protect her and then she
awkwardly thank you gosh this simp he's
way too excited and moving on Lee
quickly ignites a special Jutsu and
overpowers this guy and drives him into
the sky and po drives him but then he
realizes that he's now used up most of
his power and now he's too tired his
ears start bleeding and he can't walk
the enemy reveals the human eardrum
breaks with sounds of over 150 MHz and
he just destroyed his semicircular Canal
within his eardrum the enemy's jutu is
the ability to control ultrasonic waves
and air pressure and Lee is now dizzy
and can walk he puts up a good fight but
quickly gets defeated the enemy Reveals
His judu is faster than the speed of
sound and the kid realizes he's about to
die meanwhile other candidates have
found Naruto Squad this girl Eno here
decides if they should help their old
childhood friends nearby all alone
Sasuke tries to defend her friends but
gets held a knife Point hating that
she's always a damsel in distress she
cuts off her signature haircut and frees
her of her old identity as blah blah
blah moving on I don't care using
substitution jutsu charges at this guy
and disappears and reappears from above
she then gets stabbed by the enemy but
realizes she's taking it like a champ
landing and biting the out of him
like a boss baby in the making but then
gets beat up but still holds on Enos
group watches from the distance and sees
her old friend overcoming her fighting
Fierce and then they finally show up to
defend her and the team and then one of
Eno's crew gets too scared to fight and
then he tries to run off but they call
him fat and that oh boy was their
biggest mistake Choi the fat I mean big
boned boy is about to let these bad guys
know what's up he combines expansion
Jutsu Leaf sty taijutsu and morphs into
a huge human meatball holy smokes and
charges at him and Slams on him well the
others tag team one guy uses Shadow
paralysis Jutsu and Eno Minds control
this guy threatening to kill her if they
don't go away but the bad guys at attack
their own teammate and shocks Eno's team
they reveal their goal isn't to win this
game it isn't to get the Scrolls it's
Sasuke they want him and they realize
there's no way they can beat them and
they're out of ideas but that's when
Lee's teammate shows up way more hard
and way tougher and way more badass but
it's too late Sasuke's body starts
emitting smoke and he wakes up just like
that and freaks everyone out and
realizes something is horrifying wrong
with him it's the curse marks he tells
Sakura to not worry and approaches
Orochi maro's team realizing his chakras
are too powerful this guy tries to
attack the others tell him to stop but
Sasuke pins him down and breaks his arm
and smiles and uses far Jutsu sharing
even Sakura at the monster he's becoming
aiming for the last bad guy he tries to
kill him but Saga stops him last minute
and transform him back to normal the bad
guy bows to Sasuke and gives him their
scroll and says that he's too strong
telling him he must report back to his
boss but promises next time he'll defeat
him and he reveals they don't know who
Orochimaru is and they were just
following orders and they don't even
know why their boss didn't kill him or
leave the curse mark so the gang
reunites and Naruto wakes up and they
fill him in on what just happened but no
one realizes that the others have
already broken the test record and have
finished it in 4 hours earlier than the
previous record they rest for 2 days and
after with less than one day left they
think most of the students have already
passed and Naruto suspects that they
should open the ninja schroll but this
stranger stopped them out of nowhere
this classes guy but he's not an enemy
and he's already has enough Scrolls to
pass and reveals he's on the way to the
Tower and they can tag along if they
want but warns them that the last few
students are waiting around the tower to
catch people who have already have both
scrolls and they need to watch out for
traps and they should approach the tower
slow and sneaky and hidden but they
quickly realized that they've gone in
circles and someone must be using
genjutsu on them and that's when they
suddenly sense enemies are approaching
them Naruto tries to attack them but he
can't touch them confused if they are
clone that can harm them or just
Illusions Sasuke realizes he's too weak
to help thanks to his neck Mark the
enemies approach them and ask for the
strolls and the group quickly tries to
figure out where the real enemy is
hiding okayo it seems like they're
screwed they could have beaten these
guys by relying on The Village's
political instability seriously let me
explain this would have been a much
better approach and it goes to show how
important it is to learn information
about the enemy before the tests really
begin it's not from the looks of this
ninja there are certain kinds of ninjas
that are known for their dark pasts and
you should notice that he used a very
specific hand seal before using his
powerful technique and this indicates
some type of vulnerability during the
preparation phase which we can use if I
was Naruto here and since I'm still full
of energy I would have relied on more
clone judu and split them into two teams
one to engage this dude and the other to
fall back to go on top of the trees and
get a bigger view of the area and to
spot any extra important pieces of
information and also to provide better
Recon on this ninja techniques and any
potential weakness they might have have
this would have also given us a buffer
and more time to coordinate with mine
and Sasuke's attacks by potentially
combining our powers with Sasuke's
Firebase Jutsu creating a rapid fire
more powerful and unpredictable attacks
focusing on the leader of the group the
moment they spotted him would have also
helped because by neutralizing him it
would have disrupted this group's
coordination especially because Sasuke
could have also used his powers to
analyze the Ninja's movements and
spotted weaknesses to relate to the team
on the Fly Naruto comes up with a plan
and he clones himself again and leads
the gang to fight with the last of their
strength till morning now they're
getting too exhausted and they collapse
and the enemy finally comes out but
that's when the gang appears behind them
it makes the enemy realize they've been
set up and Naruto used his clone power
to also clone his teammates full of
energy now and ready to attack Naruto
punches this bad guy but this bad guy
does a reverse Uno and the group
realizes the real bad guys are still
fake and the Real Enemy jumps from
behind making Sasuke realize their power
they're using Earth style judu and
attack from behind their clones and this
is how they're physically harming them
with their clones figuring this out they
quickly disarm the bad guy and win the
death match match but Sasuke starts to
sense that this glasses guy is Hing them
out for no reason and is kind of
suspicious reaching the tower he wishes
them well and heads into a separate door
and reports to someone that he has
analyzed and filed a report on Naruto's
Powers now they know his and Sasuke's
strength and weaknesses and reports it
to his boss Orochimaru and Naruto's team
reaches and gets congratulated on
passing the second exam to become one of
78 test takers Left Alive and makes
Naruto one step closer to reaching his
epic dreams of becoming the ultimate
ninja and Hokage of the Hidden leaf
Village but what do you think about the
video don't forget to like subscribe and
leave a comment down below and as always
don't forget to check out our how toe
playlist